if the director always the first one on
set would you sometimes see other crew
members actors show up before you and
what did that say about them there are
some actors don't mention their names
but there they are so involved in
legitimacy of what they do they're there
before the crew and me
they just sit on this set and sit in the
seat they know they're gonna be in
sometimes or if they're if it's supposed
to be their bedroom they'll go on their
bedroom and touch the props and do what
is never become familiar with the
pictures on the wall and what's in the
closet what kind of bed sheets are they
what color is the bedding how soft of
the pillows and why those pills that
software they harder or is the blind
closed or is it open and it's a curtains
on the wall and why was that color
chosen for this sheet and ah okay and
they're comfortable because it's their
bedroom for the last 15 years so
sometimes they come to this set two days
before and they just sit there and they
become organically engrained some of the
great actors have their own ways of
becoming the truth of what they're
supposed to be and I get there and
they're there hey Bill how you doing man
no idea you know what I'm doing working
I see yeah thank you because I respect
that they don't just wait for you to
tell them what to do they have their own
because I'm an actor too as you start
serve rendering to a character that the
author is written it's it's gonna sound
crazy but the character tries to live
through you if you accept him or her I
was playing a character once in a movie
forgot which one it was
and week before us pulls a film I
started doing this never done that my
life my girl for the times what are you
doing I said wait she said she's going I
said no I'm not she says okay I watch my
own this later I'm going
that was the character coming through me
and so I put that in part of the film
because I knew something that is being
expressed to one person and it's trust
trusting your instincts yourself and
your talent so if an actor wants to do
all those things bring little
idiosyncrasies or ticks or or show up
three hours early it is that something
that they almost feel like they need
permission to do because I could see a
new actor wanting to do those things but
being scared because they don't want to
offend anybody or whatever you're a new
actor and and you know what acting is
and you have a good director they'll
give you the permission that you need to
do and be the best you can good
directors their ego is listening if I'm
shooting a scene with the star of the
movie in a car and we shot half the
scene for lunch and should have the
scene after lunch and the an intern an
assistant or a caterer comes up to me
says hay bale bill I say what the
license plates before he went plunge was
straight but now it's crooked
I don't say you're the caterer you're an
assistant mind your own business that's
stupid I say thank you very much because
I didn't see that and I have my
assistant coming straight at the license
plate you know why because I still get
directing credit that purse is no less
than me that person helped me out but
some people throw the phones that I
don't they don't understand these idiots
going phones in people's faces and this
is real t-wave like they're superior to
human beings and an attitude of
superiority like other people earth it's
annoying because they're all gonna die
they all bleed and I do believe have no
proof of course I don't want it that
money I'll go to the bathroom and do
number two they stink if they don't if
they can prove they don't stink when
they go to the bathroom I will worship
them but until that moment occurs don't
come to me with that crap yours that you
stink I stink you're boasting cool do
your damn job so we're gonna assume that
they do if you're asking me if I'm going
in the bathroom I'm not I'm saying we're
yeah we'll just we'll we'll err on the
side of caution of course great course
yes good nice suit error
yeah yeah yeah Arizona that's all right
though she said she's here
you